en effet dès l'annoncé des premiers
résultats et au jeu du taux d'abstention
record de nombreuses voix se sont
élevées pour demander le report du
second tour
c'est le cas par exemple de françois
ruffin yannick jadot ou encore marine le
pen j'appelle solennellement le
président de la république à faire
prévaloir en toutes circonstances la
santé des français et ceux dorénavant
dans la plus complète transparence je
lui demande de réunir dès demain matin
les représentants des forces politiques
pour tirer toutes les leçons de ce
premier tour et je lui demande
d'organiser avec ses forces politiques
le report du second tour
je veux le faire avant de connaître des
résultats je demande le report du second
tour avec une abstention record avec une
campagne impossible le maintenir serait
mauvais pour la santé des citoyens mais
aussi pour celle de la démocratie
compte tenu de tous les témoignages qui
remontent de tous les services
hospitaliers et de l'expérience que nous
devons tirer de la situation chez nos
voisins le second tour n'aura
manifestement pas lieu compte tenu de
l'aggravation prévisible de l'épidémie
il faut donc considérer comme acquise
les nombreuses élections qui ont vu les
candidats être élu au premier tour et
reporter les autres qui devront se tenir
dans quelques mois quand l'épidémie sera
jugulée
[Musique]